Magneto thank you for agreeing to meet
with me well I don't think we'll ever
agree on anything Charles but I'm always
happy to sit as friends what did you
want to see me about well how to put it
you're fired
what this isn't working for me you're
not my boss you cannot fire me and yet I
just did I just can't have such a lame
archenemy I'm just so tired of hearing
you whine about mutants are the future
mutants are the future look at this one
he's got webbed toes shouldn't he be
President you're beginning to try my
patience Charles right your lame powers
look out everyone magneto is attacking
us with rudimentary science you should
fear me Charles
oh I do I don't stand a chance against
you in a third grade science fair you're
down you're the mutant equivalent of a
baking soda volcano you're done piping
hot come back magnet man well what's so
cool about you anyway my unprecedented
psychic ability oh right I forgot you're
a psychic what's your 900 number again
clever almost as clever as your name
Magneto I mean I use the power of my
mind
should I be mind oh yes but one thing
you may not have noticed is nito is in
there like neato people like that you're
telling me that people like that the
word neato is hidden in your name yes of
course anyway it's better than your name
Professor X yeah it's a job followed by
a letter O behold my power
I'm children's dentist n if I were a
children's dentist named Ned I would go
by them you're bald also you want to
make fun of heads wearing that helmet
this helmet is ingenious it prevents you
from reading my thoughts and does the
Cape do that as well or do you just like
looking like a live-action role
well would you prefer that I wear a
Men's Wearhouse style suit you look like
a college basketball coach standing on
the sidelines or in your case City ring
the bell
somebody made a wheelchair joke boom you
think I need to be in this chair I can
levitate a goddamn aircraft carrier with
the power of my mind I could certainly
float myself up like you do but I don't
feel the need to advertise my powers
like a desperate for attention magnetic
David Blaine you look like a giant bald
baby look like a teenage girls tube of
lip balm you look like mr. clean at a
job interview who looked like a tool
that tells us the gender of a fetus you
look like a white Steve Harvey you're
quite gifted with words max is that how
you managed to recruit such a impressive
Brotherhood of mutant good group what do
you got a toad and a fat guy do you want
to talk about teams let's talk about
team you have a guy whose skeleton is
made of metal the one thing that I
control are I fired Wolverines ass he's
worth us Oh for real yes is a piece of
garbage and I tossed him then we finally
agree on something you know who you
should fire who's that your stylist you
look like a Trojan warrior who's real
into Madonna oh okay I see how it is if
you're psychic what am I thinking now I
have that power as well nice metal watch
I have another hand as do i telekinesis
beats magnets
Touche child socket max eat a dick
Charles
[Music]
Charles we're being silly old habits
indeed shall we discuss peace the fate
of the world is at stake I agree I hope
you accept my apology of course old
friend one of our gifted youngsters drew
that thought it would be nice to share
it off you've in refrigerator
[Music]